RESPONSE TO THE CALL BUT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS HANDED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE TO SYRIA
JUST MONTHS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TWO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL CAN REQUIRE
HOW IT WILL BE. IN A SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TESTAMENT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN IT I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PURCHASE NUMBER. CODE.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE NUMBER IS. NINE SEVEN FOUR
FIVE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTABLE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
BOARD COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MONITOR
TO DIAL ONE. FOR SUPPORT AND.
TO PRECIPICE ONLY TIME AND
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT WHAT
YOU RECEIVE LINE NUMBER YOU
WAIT ON THE- FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL. FOR AT THAT TIME YOU WANT
ME TO. SEND YOU A NOW. TO
ADDRESS THE- PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID A FEEDBACK
SUBMITTED OF YOU'RE BEING. ON
AN TESTIMONY FOR THE PHONE. WE
FROM YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAKE THE
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS JUST MAYBE REMOVE FROM
THE RIVER MODE MEETING. AND FOR
THIS DID OR MEET. OKAY IT MAY
TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING AND
COULD A HEARING AS CLOSE TO
SAME MANNER AS DISCUSS. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAW TIME FOR
BRITISH. WHO ARE TO THE NEW USE
OF A TOOLS FOR. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES THAT THE CAN
BE HEARD. BEFORE WE BEGIN THE
LEAD PROCESS AND BUSINESSES
THIS HEARING I WANTED TO A
MOMENT TO A THE OF MARIE. AND
ONE SAILOR. THE SINK IN THE M.
S. ASSAULT VEHICLE OFF COAST OF
KEY. WE THANK FOR THEIR SERVICE
AND THEIR SACRIFICE. I KNOW I
SPEAK FOR ALL OF MY CAR WHEN I
SAY WE WILL NEVER STOP WORKING.
HEY ARE DEAD BETTER. TO THEIR-
TO THIS GREAT NATION. THERE IS
NOTHING WE CAN SAY THAT WILL
MAKE THE PAIN OF THEIR LOSS ANY
EASIER BUT OUR OPTION HARPER
FIRST OUR HEARTS ARE WITH THE
GRIEVING FOR. THEIR SERVICE OUR
NAY WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN.
HERE ARE THE NAMES OF THE LIVES
LOST FROM BRAVO COMPANY
BATTALION LANDING TEAM WON
FIRST BATTALION FOURTH MARINES
FIFTEEN MARINE EXPEDITIONARY
UNIT. LANCE CORPORAL GARREL
ASPERA'S TWENTY FIVE NEW
BRADFORD TEXAS RIFLEMAN PRIVATE
FIRST CLASS BRIAN J. POTTERY A
NINETEEN OF CORONA CALIFORNIA
RIFLEMAN. LANCE CORPORAL MARCO
A. N. BARKER BARCAROLLE TWENTY
ONE OF MONTEBELLO CALIFORNIA
RIFLEMAN. PRIVATE FIRST CLASS
EVER IN A BATH NINETEEN OAK
CREEK WISCONSIN RIFLEMAN. US
BABY HOW FUHRMAN CHRISTOPHER J.
M. TWENTY TWO OF STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL CORPSMAN.
PRIVATE FIRST CLASS RYAN OR
BOARD SHE TWENTY ONE OF BEND
OREGON RIFLEMAN. CORPO WEST A
ROD TO THREE OF HARASSED. RIGHT
LANCE CORPORAL CHANGE THE SWEET
WOULD NINETEEN OF PORTLAND
OREGON FOR RIFLEMAN. CORPO SEES
EIGHT BAIL NO I HAVE A TWENTY
ONE OF RIVERSIDE CAL. RIFLEMAN
WE ALSO SEND OUR WISHES FOR THE
FAST RECOVERY OF THE MARINES
INJURED IN THE SAME ACCIDENT.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN THE
FLOOR TO ANY COMMENTS. BUT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I THINK
I'VE SAID IT ALL TO THE
FAMILIES I HAD THE HONOR TO
MEET WITH ONE OF THE FAMILIES
IN MONTEBELLO YESTERDAY. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE GOVERNOR WE SEND
OUR CONDOLENCES THANK YOU
LATEST GENTLEMEN TAKE YOUR
SEATS. THANK YOU WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH TODAY'S AGENDA
LISTS ESTABLISH A QUORUM I'D
LIKE TO REMIND MEMBERS TO TURN
ON THEIR MICROPHONES.
CONSULTANT PARTULA HERE THAT'S
WHAT I HEAR GROVE WHAT THE-
HERE WITH FELLOW HERE NIELSEN.
ROTH ROTH HERE AMBERG. AMBERG
HERE WILK PRESIDENT WELL
PRESENT YOU HAVE A QUORUM SIR
WE HAVE A CO THE CONSULTANT HAS
A STAB WE HAVE A QUORUM JOE. WE
HAVE THREE BILLS ON THIS OUR
CALENDAR TODAY. THE COMMITTEE
WILL LOOK AT. ONE TWO OR
CONSENT. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SO MOVE
MISTER CHAIRMAN. I HAVE A
CONSENT CALENDAR APPROVAL AND
MOVE BY CENTER WILK. AGAIN
PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON
CHIP EVERYONE CAN HEAR YOUR
VOTE. WHEN MADE. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PARTULA
BY FLORIDA I GROWTH. THAT'LL
FIVE BATTLE I NIELSEN. ROTH
ROTH HI NUMBER ALL RIGHT NUMBER
I WELL HI WELL I. NOW LET'S
HEAR FROM OUR THAT THE ACCOUNT
PLEASE. CONSULT ALL RIGHT. NOW
IT'S YOUR OUR AUTHOR AB THREE
ONE. AND WHAT AS MEMBER IRWIN
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR AND
SENATORS TODAY I AM PRESENTING
AB THREE THREE SEVEN ONE WHICH
AMENDS THE DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OF THE ANNUAL
SUICIDES AMONG VETERANS IN CAL
REPORT. THIS SITE IS A TRAGIC
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM THAT CAN
AND SHOULD BE PROVIDED BY
INCREASED AWARENESS AND
SUITABLE MEANT. THE FIRST
REPORT RELEASED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN REGRETFULLY ONLY
CONTAIN TWO PAGES. THE SECOND
REPORT RELEASED IN JUNE OF THIS
YEAR WAS DOUBLE IN LENGTH BUT
STILL ONLY ANALYZED HIM- THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR FOUR PAGES.
THIS BRIEF ANALYSIS IS EVEN
MORE CONCERNING IS THE CONTENTS
OF THE REPORT IDENTIFIED
DISTURBING STATISTICS INCLUDING
STANDARD NINETY SUICIDE. DEATHS
AMONG CAL VETERANS THAT VETERAN
SUICIDE DEATHS MADE UP 16% OF
ALL SUICIDES IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND OVER
REPRESENTATION BY OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PERCENT. THE
CURRENT REPORTS CONTAINED
INSUFFICIENT DATA TO DRAW ANY
CONCLUSIONS OR INFERENCES TO
WHICH ON WHICH. TO EIGHT TAKE
ACTION OR IMPLEMENT POLICY. A
THREE THREE SEVEN AMENDS THE
DATE REPORTING. TO GATHER
FURTHER DEMOGRAPHIC DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION TO COMPARE CURRENT
AND PAST DATA TO IDENTIFY
TRENDS. WE MUST IT BILL THIS
YEAR AS THE REPORT FLAG. THE
DATA COLLECTION LYFT LONG FOR
THIS REPORT. THE REPORT
RELEASED IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR
CAME DATA FOR EIGHTEEN ANY
DELAY IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS BILL WILL BE COMPOUNDED BY
THE TWO YEAR DELAY IN AVAILABLE
DATA. THANK YOU UP BY RICK ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS TODAY. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN. DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIR MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH WILL BE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES. FOLLOW
THE QUESTION A TO. MUST LIMIT
THEIR COM TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATE AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. LET BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO ALL THREE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT.I SEE NO ONE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM. ONE ONE
TWO. I SEE NO ONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY THREE SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU NOW WILL MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELEPHONE. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE WE WILL BEGIN.
PLEASE JOIN ME ON THE PHONE
LINE IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE ONE ZERO. TIME AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SOME. THAT IS WHY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO BE JUST A
MOMENT. MODERATOR HOW MANY
WITNESSES- TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. WE ARE NONE LOOKS
LIKELY TO HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE
OKAY KERETA HEAD. JUST A MOMENT
HERE. AND SO THE FIRST PERSON
WILL GO TO WILL BE- AT NUMBER
TWELVE AT NUMBER TWELVE THE
LINE. THANK YOU DON'T HAVE
SHOWN THAT ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATE BUILDERS CONTRACTORS
OF NORTH AND- INTO. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'RE ON SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SO ONE PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. MONTEREY POLICE PROP ANY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
THREE ONE MORE TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR.
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
OF THE SUPPORTERS. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY THREE FORTY TWO OH THREE
WHICH SHE TESTIFIED OPPOSITION.
I SEE NONE BUT THERE ANY
WITNESSES A ROOM ONE ONE TWO.
WHO WISH TO TEST NOT. AB.
THIRTY THREE SEVENTY ONE. I SEE
NONE. THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESS. TO TESTIFY VIA
TELEPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY THREE SEVENTY ONE. AND
NOW IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. THE RAIDERS AND IN OUR
QUEUE. WHETHER SOMEONE IN THE
QUEUE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NOBODY IN OUR QUEUE. MONTEREY
TO PLEASE- PROP THE WITNESSES.
ONE MORE TIME IN OPPOSITION AB
THIRTY THREE SEVENTY ONE.
ABSOLUTELY AND ONCE AGAIN LAYS
IN GERMAN THE CURRENT
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND THAT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU I'D LIKE
TO THANK A THOSE WHO CALLED IN.
ALASKA ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS LET ME TURN IT OVER.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING THE- NONE. I
HAVE WITH THE MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL FOR WE GO ON I'D LIKE
TO. LIKE ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
CENTER ONE. OF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. WITH. I'M SURE EVERY
REYES GO HOME SO I WILL HAVE A
RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR- IN OUR
MOTION MOVED BILL BY. WILK A.
BASH BUT FOR RE REFER TO A-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS ARE.
FIVE ROTHE. BUT HI THE I AM.
ROTH BROWN I NUMBERED NUMBER I
WELL CON WELL I. FIVE ZERO.
BUILT ON SIR THANK. AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF THE
HISTORY TOGETHER AND TO
EVERYONE WHO'S THIS. VIEW WERE
NOT ABLE TO. TODAY SAID YOUR OR
SHOULD. WRITING TO THE VETERANS
AFFAIRS. OR VISIT THE WEB. YOUR
COMMON AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT. TO ALL OF US WE WANT
TO BE INCLUDE IN THE TESTIMONY.
ON THIS DURING AND THE RED.
THANK YOU SHAPE YOUR
PARTICIPATION.